This is how I prepared for my interview to get my job at Squarespace.
What better way to apply for a job at a website company than to make an actual website?
So, I made a one-page website about myself.
Once I got the hang of it, I could speak to the product in the interview,...
...and actually show them a bit about me, my personality,...
...and my work experience with a website.
So, of course, I researched the company itself,...
...I researched the folks that I'd be interviewing with.
I had a friend actually guide me through a fake interview...
...where we just pulled questions from the internet that we thought might come up,...
...which kind of helped me get the scaries out.
Before I went into the interview, I did a boxer move,...
...listened to really energetic music and psyched myself up.
Self affirmations like "You got this!"
...so that I could really walk in feeling energized.
One thing that I took into consideration...
...is just sort of how I present myself, my posture and my confidence.
I wanted to make sure I wasn't slouching and being too casual,...
...although the hiring manager did tell me it was a very casual environment.
I wanted to make sure that I demonstrated to him...
...that I was confident and poised and ready for the role.